the best that the coronavirus could have
done is just delayed
and it probably did you know this this
maybe would have happened you know
three months ago if it wasn't for the
chronovirus um
but the the these unresolved tensions
man i can
it's totally valid to feel like we're in
sort of fall of the republic territory
here
because we are i mean this is uh you
know probably something like crisis of
the third century if we're comparing
western civilization to rome uh so i
think we probably do have a couple
hundred years
left to go but i think it's evident that
whatever we've been doing to bring us to
this point
is leading us on a path to destruction
something's wrong
right yeah something's wrong something's
deeply wrong
this was probably built into the
enlightenment
uh which i i'm not i don't relish to
have to say
because you know i i'm a product of it
and i believe in the ideals
but you have to be honest about the
things that are going wrong and these
people are pushing for like absolute
freedom and they seem to be wanting
to destroy everything that we have it
took a long time to get to this position
and
it was very a lot of hard work from a
lot of good people and i'm not prepared
to call them all bad people because the
moral standards have changed
you know that's and it's unacceptable
it's it what's really insulting about
that
is it's essentially saying that the
roman empire's army could never have
learned to use guns
right because we we don't like morality
develops over time you know we there
there's a time when literally no one on
earth questioned the institution of
slavery why would you what the hell are
you talking about
you know and then there became a time
where people did start questioning it
then it came a time
where it was essentially a moral
revolution where we're like no there
can't be any slavery
you know then it then democracy comes no
everyone should have the franchise why
should these people
say okay this is great and it's the same
as developing this you know so we're
saying that
like people back in you know the 16th
century or whatever
you know if they had been raised now
or you know introduced to our ideas our
concepts they couldn't
have believed that actually they were so
innately deficient that they they had
poorer morals inbuilt into them not that
they were just a product of their
environment
exactly which is amazing for the
philosophy that views everything as a
political
contextual battle you know but yeah
exactly
you know they are the product of their
time you know that's what
what do you expect most people end up
representing the societies in which
they've been
raised and their society had normalized
moral standards that we think are
terrible and it's only because we've got
a different society that everyone agrees
you know
and so it's it seems to be doing them a
great disservice it's
awful it's it's a jordan petersonism
where he talks about how
um people that believe that if they were
back
in maui china or in uh stalin's russia
that they would have done it differently
that they would have behaved differently
and it's like you would have to be an
extraordinary
human for that to be the case and if
you're a determinist then
you know well yeah yeah but i mean but
no but that's
that's exactly the point it's like why
why would you think that they
wouldn't react rationally to the
pressures that have been put on them
right because they they are they you
know it's a rational reaction in the in
the situation that they're in it might
not be a good one
but you'll you'll when you're in their
place you'll see why they took those
decisions and
depending on the kind of person you are
you might take them too
that's then there must be an element of
this on the other side of the fence
though on the
black lives matter protesters that have
a small minority
who have tried to potentially hijack
this movement to move it toward
ends that the vast majority of people
that are supporting it
don't actually want and then they're
kind of getting dragged along and
they're again they're products
of perhaps the the loudest the most
machiavellian
i don't know how it works and the main
oh no you're spot on that's exactly how
it works the main problem that
i can see is that without a single
leader for black lives matter
from a distributed leadership
we can always continue to move forward
perspective that's great
but from a negotiation perspective so
that you can actually start to
move forward productively with the rest
of the world
like who do you talk to yeah there's a
problem with um
the sort of secular religion that has
become
uh the the the radical left-wing
essentially it is all an aspect of
communism i would say
uh the the idea of borders and
boundaries
the people following it don't think that
so how of course
how have they adopted or how have they
uh internalized this like who's who's
giving it to them
um people who are very clever people who
have been training
for this this is people have been
studying for this
for their whole lives and this is what
robin d'angelo is talking about you know
this
they're very very carefully thought
about these things and
they're very good at laundering their
ideas through other ideas that are
totally reasonable you know
we want police reform totally reasonable
that means defund the police
totally unreasonable you know there's a
there's not only one way of doing it
[Music]